[موسيقى]
طبعا تم اختياري كوني انسان كفيف لاداره
هذا المخيم بعد تجربه كانت حقيقه يعني غير
ناجحه لاداره مبصر للمكفوفين طبعا الكفيف
حقيقه يعني له جو خاص
وحقيقه عقليه خاصه فالحمد لله حتى الان
كونك كفيف
الحقيقه استطيع ان اصل الفكره ما بين
الكفيفه وبين المجتمع الخارجي بجميع اطياف
والحمد لله
[موسيقى]
قريه النور هي مخطط مخصصه للمكفوفين فيها
شغلات يعني بتساعد الكفيف انه يمشي عن
طريق الحيط انه يتلمس انه يعرف بيته كيف
عن طريق
الحروف النافره عن طريق الحجر النافذ عن
طريق الطرق المبلطه انه يتساعد ما يتفشكل
في الطرقات
[موسيقى]
انا انا مسكر لجنه عباره عن
نائب مدير ولجني قائمه على الاعمال
اللوجستي والحمد لله عن طريق تعاوني انا
هذه اللجنه الحمد لله ننجز عمل مميز جدا
مميز جدا في الشمال السوري وخصوصا بعد
اداره مخيم الكوفيين
نتيجه الزلزال الذي حدث في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]